Speaker 1: All right. Listen, I am not here
to sing the praises of Mark Zuckerberg, but
I have to tell you that I am delighted by what is
going on with Meadows recently launched Twitter,
a competitor called Threads. I joined Threads last
night. You can you can see my profile there. I
am David Packman on Threads and I would love for
you to follow me. What is this? What is this all
about? Axios has a good article explaining
it. Meadows Twitter competitor for, quote,
friendly conversation launches early Elon Musk's
blunders with Twitter are gifting Mark Zuckerberg
an opportune opening for a new rival app threads
launched last night at 7 p.m. Eastern. They were
going to debut it today, Thursday, but they ended
up debuting it early. It's available on Android
and the Apple Store. I don't know what it's called
now, the iTunes store. I don't know anything about
iPhones. I'm sorry, but it's on it's available
on Android and Apple phones, that's for sure.
A bunch of things that Elon Musk has done recently
have particularly set up the environment for some
kind of Twitter competitor. There was this rate
limit where if you were not verified on Twitter,
if you're not paying for Twitter, you can only see
600 tweets a day. It's pretty bonkers stuff. Then
Twitter announced that its TweetDeck dashboard
will become available only to paying subscribers.
I mean, quite frankly, Elon Musk is making blunder
after blunder. I know that much like with Jordan
Peterson, there are people with Elon Musk that
say, David, if you think he's making mistakes,
it's because you don't understand the genius of
what he's doing. I had people emailing me saying,
David, you know what Elon Musk is doing is
actually genius. He's reducing bandwidth costs
by limiting the number of tweets that you can see.
And it's all 4D chess and it's just all completely
and totally incredible. All right. I just don't
seem to think that's the case. My activity on
Twitter is down to almost zero, and so is that of
so many of the people that I follow because it's
just become a bad experience. So comes threads.
Threads is connected to matter. You can log into
threads with your Instagram account. Not only
am I now on threads, the David Packman show is
on threads. We're looking at becoming early
adopters when it comes to posting our video
content there. We're not exactly yet. Sure, sure.
Whether this can be automated in some way. From a
technical standpoint, if anybody happens to
know, please let us know. We're working on
it and will soon be up to speed. Elon Musk's
comment on all of this last night was, quote,
It is infinitely preferable to be attacked by
strangers on Twitter than indulge in the false
happiness of hide the pain. Instagram, of course,
referring to the idea that Threads is seeking to
be a sort of more positive environment, less about
trolling and insults and this sort of thing. Now,
what are my real thoughts about this? Because
as as I'm sure you know, if you know me,
you know that I am not about picking the right
billionaire whose horse I'm going to attach my
buggy to, or whatever the case may be, we relying
on one possible sociopath to defeat another is not
like a thrilling and super exciting strategy
for the future of humanity. I am not naive to
the undeniable reality that Metters threads is
just another attempt to monopolize the online
discourse for profit and control of the narrative.
Okay. I mean, like, okay, so Twitter has been
failing to do it recently. So now in comes Mark
Zuckerberg and whatever the case may be, are we
all pining for another corporate can? Trolled
platform? Not really. Am I concerned that what
happened on Facebook around recent elections, the
spread of disinformation, COVID, disinformation,
election disinformation, it could just take
over threads as well? Of course I'm concerned
about that. Of course I'm concerned about that.
And unfortunately, some of these decentralized
sort of attempts to replace Twitter have
flopped. Mastodon was one which I mean, listen,
I got on there within 10 seconds. I knew it was
going nowhere. I'm sorry. I know people still
email me and say, David, when are you getting on
Mastodon? I'm on it. Nobody knows because there's
100 different servers, and if you're not on
the same server, you have no idea. I'm on
it. I listen. I'm sorry. I'm sorry, okay? I don't
think Mastodon is it? Blue Sky, I thought was very
interesting. I was concerned that by limiting the
number of new users that could sign up, Blue Sky
was vulnerable to something like threads coming
forward. I'm still on blue sky. Blue Sky now has
announced they are pausing new member signups. I
mean, I still am holding out hope for blue sky,
but it seems as though it's not going particularly
well. So on the one hand, I am thrilled that the
idea of a more functional no rate limits, no,
you know, all of this whacked out stuff that's
happening on Twitter. I like that. I think
that that's a good thing. There's a functional
verification system still on threads because it's
using the Instagram verification system. I think
that these things are good. On the other hand,
I can only imagine that Meadows real agenda here
is to continue building this environment in which
you've got Facebook and WhatsApp and Instagram and
threads and they're building the metaverse and on
and on and on. And Metta goes in the direction of
dominating our digital lives and and taking away
autonomy and potentially hurting democracy. So
I'm curious about threads. I'm on threads. We're
going to start using it as a tool to promote our
content. I'm skeptical. I don't know how meta is
going to ensure that Threads just doesn't end up
with the exact same misinformation problems that
Facebook and Instagram quite frankly, had around
elections and COVID disinformation. So find me on
threads at David Dot Pac-Man. The show is there
at David Pacman Show. It's actually small enough
still where I'm seeing everybody who's responding
to me. So like on Twitter, it's a lost cause.
It's just totally out of control on threads. I'm
actually seeing everybody, so follow me there
and we'll see what we end up doing with it.